[Music]  let's have ambitions for the future of  this continent  for the future of the european way of  life  [Music]  the basic principle about the  functioning of the european union  is democracy i want to strengthen the  european parliament in this regard  because it's the only institution  which is finally directly elected by the  citizens of europe  we have to to show leadership and that  means  to look beyond the today's challenges i  think the main task for the future is  to play a role on global level having  china russia u.s in mind we have to be  stronger on international affairs a lot  of people are skeptical about  the the deepening of the european union  they have to be  listening that we want to invite people  we want to to listen to people  and i want to see as much as possible  debates all over europe  taking the people's concern and the  people's perspective into account  is a starting point for the conference  the future is  in your head is in your hands